IMPORTANT THAN SCORING CHEAP
POLITICAL POINTS AGAINST A
PRESIDENT YOU DIDN'T VOTE FOR.
DON'T YOU THINK?
THAT'S THE "ANGLE."
NOW AS PROMISED MY EXCLUSIVE
INTERVIEW WITH ATTORNEY FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
RUDY GIULIANI.
WE ARE JOINED BY FORMER NEW YORK
MAYOR AND COUNSEL TO THE TRUMP
TEAM.
YOU MADE A LOT OF NEWS LAST TIME
YOU WERE ON THE NETWORK.
WHAT WAS THE ISSUE?
REIMBURSEMENT OF PAYMENTS TO
MICHAEL COHEN FOR THE STORMY
DANIELS SETTLEMENT.
WE FOUND OUT THE PRESIDENT DID
DISCLOSE THAT.
WAS THIS DONE A COUPLE OF WEEKS
>> YES, AND THE PRESIDENT WAS
AWARE OF IT AND ENDORSED A
STRATEGY.
WE WOULD NOT DO IT WITHOUT HIM.
HE IS THE SILENT.
HE HAS TREMENDOUS JUDGMENT ABOUT
THINGS LIKE THIS.
THEY AGREED WITH US IT HAD BEEN
FULLY DISCLOSED.
I HAD A LITTLE DISAGREEMENT WITH
HIM BUT IT'S PETTY.
I DON'T BELIEVE IT HAD TO BE
EXPOSED.
I SAY IT WAS AN EXPENDITURE.
>> Laura: AND HE SAYS IT'S A
LIABILITY?
>> IT'S IMPORTANT FOR DISCLOSURE
PURPOSES.
WHICH WE DECIDED OUT OF CAUTION
WE WOULD DISCLOSE THIS.
>> Laura: HE SAID THAT THE
PAYMENT MADE BY MR. MICHAEL
COHEN IS REQUIRED TO BE REPORTED
AS A LIABILITY.
>> WE AGREE WITH THAT.
HE DISCLOSED IT.
WE DON'T AGREE -- I DON'T AGREE
IT'S A LIABILITY.
BECAUSE I KNOW THE NATURE OF IT.
IT DIDN'T MATTER AT THIS POINT.
>> Laura: ANOTHER FORMER ETHICES
OFFICER SAID THIS IS A
TANTAMOUNT TO A CRIMINAL
REFERRAL.
>> [LAUGHING].
NO IT'S NOT.
YOU JUST LEAD THE LANGUAGE.
>> Laura: ANOTHER OFFICER SAID:
>> NO, IT'S NOT.
IF IT WAS IT WOULD SAY CRIMINAL
REFERRAL.
THE PRESIDENT CAN'T DISCLOSE
MORE THAN HE KNOWS.
WE ARE VERY COMFORTABLE WITH IT
AND MUELLER SHOULD BRING THIS TO
A CLOSE.
IT'S BEEN A YEAR.
1.4-MILLION DOCUMENTS AND
INTERVIEWED 28 WITNESSES AND HE
HAS NOTHING.
WHICH IS WHY HE WANTS TO BRING
THE PRESIDENT TO AN INTERVIEW.
WE DEMAND:
TELL US WHAT YOU HAVE TO GET
FROM AN INTERVIEW THAT YOU DON'T
ALREADY HAVE?
HE HAS ALL OF THE FACTS TO MAKE
A DECISION.
>> Laura: WHY WOULD YOU AGREE TO
AN INTERVIEW NOW?
A LOT OF FORMER CRIMINAL DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS HAVE MULLED THIS FOR
SOMETIME.
GIVEN EVERYTHING DISCOVERED
ABOUT HOLDING BACK DOCUMENTS,
WHY WOULD YOU AGREE UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCES TO ALLOW PRESIDENT
TRUMP TO GO THERE?
>> THERE WOULD BE A NARROW AREA
WHERE WE MIGHT AGREE IF THEY
COULD TELL US WHY THEY NEED IT.
THEY HAVE HIS EXPLANATIONS OF
EVERYTHING AND 1.4 MILLION
DOCUMENTS AND WITNESSES.
IF THEY ARE GOING TO DISBELIEVE
HIM, THEY ARE GOING TO
DISBELIEVE HIM.
THE FACT IS WE HAVE TO KNOW WHAT
DO YOU WANT CLARIFIED?
IF THEY TOLD US, IF WE GAVE THE
EXPLANATION, THEY WOULD END IT,
FINE.
WE ARE TRYING TO GET THEM TO END
THIS.
THIS IS NOT GOOD FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S OFFICE
DOESN'T UNDERSTAND THEY ARE
INTERFERING WITH THINGS BIGGER
THAN THEM OR US.
>> Laura: YOU SAID THERE IS A
PLAN-B AND C IF MUELLER DOESN'T
WRAP THIS UP.
GOING INTO THE SECOND YEAR.
YOU KNOW HOW MUCH TIME THIS
TAKES.
BILL CLINTON FOUND THAT OUT?
>> WE WILL DEMAND AN ANSWER.
WE COOPERATED BEYOND ANY OTHER
PRESIDENT EVER COOPERATED.
ALL OF THOSE DOCUMENTS, 1.4
MILLION AND ALL OF THOSE
WITNESSES.
>> Laura: WHAT IS THE PLAN-B AND
C.
FIRING MUELLER OR COMEY?
>> NO, THEN WE START FROM DAY 1
AGAIN.
WE WILL FIND OUT WHAT LEGAL
REMEDIES ARE AVAILABLE TO US
INCLUDING CHALLENGING A
SUBPOENA.
THE SAME REASON THEY CAN'T
INDICT HIM.
>> Laura: WHICH MUELLER AGREED
TO TODAY.
>> I DON'T THINK THEY AGREE TO
THE PROCESS QUESTION.
THE SAME REASON THEY CAN'T
INDICT HIM, THEY CAN'T ISSUE A
SUBPOENA TO HIM.
CLINTON OPPOSED A SUBPOENA AND
THEN VOLUNTARILY COMPLIED.
>> Laura: YOUR HOLD PAL ON MSNBC
SAID.
>> THESE FOLKS CAN'T GET THEIR
STORIES STRAIGHT.
THEY CAN'T FIGURE OUT WHAT THEY
WANT TO DO.
THEY SHOULD HAVE TOLD THE TRUTH
A LONG TIME AGO.
MR. GIULIANI HAS BEEN LYING TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ABOUT HOW
THIS OCCURRED AND WHEN IT
OCCURRED.
ACCORDING TO THE DISCLOSURE
TODAY, IT OCCURRED BACK IN 2017.
>> [LAUGHING].
I DON'T THINK I EVER CHANGED
THAT.
THE PAYMENT TOOK PLACE IN 2017.
THE REIMBURSE
THE REIMBURAL
THE REIMBURAL W
THE REIMBURAL WAS
THE REIMBURAL WAS 2
THE REIMBURAL WAS 201
THE REIMBURAL WAS 2016
THE REIMBURAL WAS 2016 A
THE REIMBURAL WAS 2016 AND
THE REIMBURAL WAS 2016 AND T
THE REIMBURAL WAS 2016 AND THE
PAYMENT WAS 2017.
HE WAS NOT THERE FOR IT.
I DON'T THINK HE IS A REAL
LAWYER.
HE IS A MAKE BELIEVE LAWYER.
HE HAS ALL KINDS OF LAWSUIT AND
I THINK HE IS TRYING TO BAIL HIM
OUT.
I DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT HIM.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT MUELLER.
AVANATI MEANS NOTHING.
>> Laura: YOU ARE NOT WORRIED
ABOUT COHEN?
>> NOT A LICK.
IT'S ONLY ABOUT MUELLER GETTING
THE DARN THING OVER WITH.
HE OWES THAT TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> Laura: THE HEAD OF THE LEFT
LEANING ETHICES GROUP, COMMITTEE
FOR RESPONSIBLE ETHICES IN
WASHINGTON, SAID, BECAUSE WE
JUST LEARNED ABOUT THIS
LIABILITY RECENTLY, THAT THE
PRESIDENT DISCLOSED, WE WONDER
WHAT OTHER LIABILITIES ARE OUT
THERE.
THEY ISSUED A LONG STATEMENT
TODAY.
THEY FILED THE ACTION THAT LED
TO THE DISCLOSURE OF THE
STATEMENTS.
>> WELL, I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE IS
TALKING ABOUT.
I CAN'T POSSIBLY RESPOND TO ALL
OF THE PRESIDENT'S POLITICAL
ENEMIES.
I IGNORE THEM.
I THINK THEIR STATEMENTS ARE NOT
WORTH ANYTHING.
WHO CARES WHAT THEY SAY?
>> Laura: HOW MANY MEETINGS HAVE
YOU HAD WITH THE MUELLER TEAM?
>> ONE.
WE HAVE FIVE LETTERS WITH THEM.
THREE GOING BACK TO DOWD FOR
THINGS WE NEED TO KNOW.
WE HAD NO RESPONSE FROM THEM.
THEY BASICALLY JUST --
>> Laura: YOU ARE ASKING FOR?
>> WHAT DO THEY REALLY NEED TO
KNOW?
WHAT KIND OF ASSURANCES DO WE
HAVE TO GET IT OVER QUICKLY LIKE
THEY DID FOR CLINTON?
I WANTED TO ASK FOR THE HILLARY
CLINTON TREATMENT.
I WANTED THE REPORT 2 WEEKS IN
ADVANCE.
LAUERING LAUERING.
-- [LAUGHING].
CLEARING MY CLIENT.
NO OATHS AND JUST AN INTERVIEW
AND QUESTIONS IN ADVANCE UPON WE
DIDN'T GET HILLARY CLINTON
TREATMENT.
THE PRESIDENT WOULD HAVE BEEN
EMBARRASSED.
>> Laura: THERE IS CONCERN THAT
THE DOJ IS NOT TURNING OVER
DOCUMENTS UNLESS THEY ARE
THREATENED WITH CONTEMPT OF
CONGRESS.
NUNES MALIGNED BY THE LIBERAL
MEDIA.
CRITICIZED FOR NOT READING SOME
DOCUMENTS.
WHAT IS YOUR SENSE, GIVEN YOUR
BACKGROUND AS A U.S. ATTORNEY,
WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS THE
ROLE THAT ROSENSTEIN HAS NOW.
I CAN'T IMAGINE NOT COMPLYING
WITH A REQUEST FOR SUCH
SENSITIVE DOCUMENTS WITH
CONGRESS.
THEY WON'T GIVE UP THE
AUTHORIZATION TO PROCEED AGAINST
MANAFORT OR AGAINST COHEN.
WHY?
JUDGE ELLIS LAID INTO THEM
PRETTY HARD.
WE WERE HAVING A PRETTY GOOD
DIALOGUE WITH THEM.
I THINK THEY ARE SHELL SHOCKED.
THEY ARE THE DARLINGS OF THE
MEDIA.
ALL OF A SUDDEN THEIR INTEGRITY
IS IN QUESTION ABOUT THE TACTICS
THEY USED.
INDICTING MANAFORT.
2005?
THE PRESIDENT DIDN'T KNOW
MANAFORT IN 2005.
IF HE DID, THERE WAS NO
MEANINGFUL RELATIONSHIP.
>> Laura: THE STORY BROKEN BY
THE RUSSIAN OLIGARCH VISITED BY
THE FBI IN NEW YORK.
HE IS ON THE SANCTIONS LIST.
VISITED BY THE FBI.
THEY SAID WE HAVE THIS IDEA THAT
PAUL MANAFORT WAS COLLUDING WITH
THE RUSSIANS FOR THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
DO YOU WANT TO HELP US?
AND A PERSON WHO CAN'T STAND
MANAFORT SAID I CAN'T LIKE THIS
GUY.
THE IDEA THAT MANAFORT IS
COLLUDING, HE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS THEM OUT OF THE ROOM.
IT DOESN'T LOOK WAS DISCLOSED.UG
IT DOESN'T LOOK WAS DISCLOSED.US
IT DOESN'T LOOK WAS DISCLOSED.UT
IT DOESN'T LOOK WAS DISCLOSED.UE
IT DOESN'T LOOK WAS DISCLOSED.U
IT DOESN'T LOOK WAS DISCLOSED.UU
IT DOESN'T LOOK WAS DISCLOSED.UF
THE ROOM.
IT DOESN'T LOOK WAS DISCLOSED.
>> IF WE WALKED INTO A HEARING
WITH THEM, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY WOULD NOT TELL US.
I KNOW THEY HAVE PLENTY -- IT'S
ABOUT TIME TO GET THE DARN THING
OVER WITH.
SAY ENOUGH.
WE TORTURED THIS PRESIDENT
ENOUGH.
MEANWHILE, LOOK AT WHAT HE
ACCOMPLISHED WITH ALL OF THIS ON
HIS BACK.
IT'S LIKE A BIG WEIGHT ON HIS
BACK.
KOREA AND CHINA.
>> Laura: MICHAEL SAID THIS.
>> IF THERE IS A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST, IT WOULD JEOPARDIZE
THE INVESTIGATION.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
WHAT ABOUT PLACING A SPY IN THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
>> Laura: DO YOU BELIEVE
HAPPENED?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> Laura: DOES THE PRESIDENT
BELIEVE THAT HAPPENED?
>> I DON'T THINK WE WANT TO
BELIEVE IT OR NOT.
PEOPLE WHO BREAK INTO MANAFORT'S
HOME IN THE MORNING IN A WHITE
COLLAR CASE WHEN HE WAS
PRODUCING DOCUMENTS WHO BREAK
INTO COHEN'S LAW OFFICE.
A LAW OFFICE.
I NEVER DID THAT AND I WAS AN
AGGRESSIVE PROSECUTOR.
I NEVER HAD THE BENEFIT OF AN
INTERVIEW TO DECIDE WHETHER TO
PROSECUTE OR NOT.
I DIDN'T NEED IT.
THESE GUYS ARE GOING BEYOND WHAT
IS NORMALLY DONE.